Charles Bronson told the parole board
his days of violence were over there'd
be no more taking hostages in prison he
promised for a long time he'd been well
behaved after 48 years behind bars he
said he'd had more porridge than
Goldilocks and the Three Bears and he
was sick of it
in a message from jail he summed up his
frustration and I keep drumming it into
the public over Danger
love the world
I'm not filthy cherished or rapist were
murdered
so we were more dangerous to our soil
Bronson was jailed for armed robbery in
1974 because of his attacks on staff and
inmates he's been locked up almost
continuously ever since much of it in
isolation
a prison psychologist told the parole
board that inside jail Bronson posed a
moderate risk of violence but if he was
freed he'd be high risk another
psychologist called by him even she said
he should probably stay in jail for now
but with a gradual release into the
community
Bronson showed the parole board some of
his artworks his drawings sell well the
panel was told he could support himself
outside prison
other artists wanted to work with him
like rapper Ice t21 who campaigns
against youth knife crime I'm hoping to
record a song with him
um make some poetry I want him to get on
stage as he suggested with me I think it
would work because a lot of people would
listen to him
um because of early years Bronson told
the parole board he was now a man of
peace I want to go home I'm an artist
born again
and that's all I've done for the last 10
years city of Marcel model prisoner
polite respectful
and they still won't let me in
no one is expecting Bronson's immediate
release or even a move to an open jail
he hopes the parole board will at least
advise a loosening of his strict prison
regime
Martin brunt Sky News